hey patronage exits Greg here so a while
ago I put out a post say user help for a
new segment let's just experiment with
this segment idea that we have it's
called trailers revisited no idea if
this video is actually going up on
YouTube since this is just us messing
around right now what the idea is is we
watch a trailer for a movie we've seen
and then we examine how inaccurate the
trailer portrayed it or if it's spoiled
too much and stuff like that reexamining
of the trailer after seeing how well did
the trailer do its job we thought we'd
start with Kyle club adventures request
which is the movie drive I remember
seeing this trailer ages ago cuz I
didn't see the trailer until way after I
saw the movie I don't know if I've ever
seen and I miss kind of the whole
cultural moment that Drive had when it
first came out like I saw this on TV on
the video with you so it was day to
watch Drive is a great day I've seen
this movie about six times let's do this
see the trailer
all the slow motion is awful I Drive
[Music]
see you Justin I nominate for a while
what are you did I Drive police a danger
it's only part-time you put this head
behind the wheel
[Music]
oh this is such a bad trip yeah
[Music]
like the whole movie feels like a be
action movie - yeah
[Music]
it was a little closer to the actual
movie
this is the entire this is all of it is
all the big surprises
[Music]
oh I'm so glad I did not watch this
trailer that is the hope is the whole
movie just not until the fun okay by the
way all right there will be there's so
much wrong with this trailer I don't
even know where to begin
tonally it doesn't capture the movie at
all but I had like the kind of opera
kind of music Indiana and they had the
smooth slow imagery that was closer to
the style of the movie yeah when they
stopped using dialogue scenes and
started kind of montaging stuff set to
like a thumping you know chronic rhythm
didn't you were like okay I can see
driving here yeah it just looked like a
be action movie it looked like a bad
action movie at that point well the
thing about that heist is that that
heist is like a major part of the story
for sure and a major turning point but
it's also not like the catalyst of the
story the problem with the trailer is
this is a very slow-moving
film when those plot points happen when
you're watching them without any idea
because you never see any of that coming
in the movie when Oscar Isaac is all
injured and then he has to talk with
Ryan Gosling the guy who's been talking
to his wife even when he gets shot
you're like I think something bad might
happen so it might not be a total
surprise an Oscar Isaac gets shot in the
movie but when it happens it's still
like a whoa it still gets you they
should like every violent scene I went
to except for the or of it they should
ever say everything they should have set
up they show that though the redhead
chick is probably in on in the betraying
Oscar Isaac they they left no stone
unturned it's the first time where I've
looked at a trailer and been like oh
yeah this really does kind of just chop
up the major bullet points of the whole
movie and run them together yeah and
like they're all great images so it
works as a trailer but like it has no
structure other than that because that
big plot of him like having to take down
these people who got Oscar Isaac killed
your money is debts paid you never go
near his family again that happens like
more than halfway through the movie so
it's a surprise it's not the feeling of
I don't care that it showed in the
trailer because obviously the movies
going that way when you watch this movie
and I have showed this movie to a few
people every time
I will show this movie to someone even
you remember my first experience I don't
know exactly where the plot is going
yeah so when it happens it's surprising
this ruins all surprises I'm so glad
this movie became popular there's a
word-of-mouth and not as a marketing no
they just took kind of every major
dialogue bit - yeah no not a lot of
dialogue so going off all this what
would have been a better trailer for dry
wood you have maybe like take in one
sequence or something and and put that
out there I think the opening scene
would have been cool I mean it's kind of
a long trailer but the getaway there's
something to do with music I would have
taken a real hero
taking a lot of the cool shots from that
but not tell you what the plot of the
movie is this morning at times I see
trailers were when I revisit them and
I'm like oh well they're actually
showing you this scene that occurs in
the finale but it doesn't ruin the movie
for me yeah those show you things that
are from late in the movie but you
they're not so blatantly that that you
can yeah like when he crashes that car
off the cliff
that doesn't necessarily ruin something
for me you know I just know yeah there's
gonna be intrigue involved yeah car cuz
there's a lot of beautiful slow-moving
lit shots in this film so I would have
taken a real hero put together some type
of two minute trailer that had
occasional violent moments in it but not
try to make it like it's about a getaway
driver who gets in a really bad mission
at Albert Brooks is is obviously crooked
bag like this thing it looks like a
super cliche awful fast-paced b-movie
yeah it looks like it's the antithesis
to what the movie is the movie has that
in its in its DNA somewhere but it's
just not yeah it's not the like crazy
violence every 10 minutes exploitation
like you think it's gonna be like
there's so much in the body language and
the restraint you know and all the the
laconic water there's no violence until
late into the movie yeah so when that
violence occurs it's shocking I bet I
bet if you see this trailer like where's
the football trick-or-treat so I could
see how people who saw this trailer and
went to go watch the movie might have
been let down because they probably
thought there's a jam-packed action
sequences jam-packed violence fast paced
snappy dialogue when it's the total
opposite yes true they're actually like
upsets me from a logical standpoint it
recaps all the events of the movie so
technically like yeah okay you're like
teasing me of the movie yeah but it does
nothing to really enhance the tone it
doesn't communicate the the heart or the
spirit of the movie because the plot
points are not exactly 100% original the
point is execution and they're not doing
anything at all to highlight the
execution of the film oh and it's about
the emotional side too like it's a very
romantically made film and so many of
the elements of the movie that make it
cool also
she weighed the feelings and expressions
man just the cool plot yeah cuz that's
what makes that's what elevates that
familiar plot and yeah without the tone
this just looks like you said like some
kind of crazy action fest b-movie Wow I
was upsetting it's also super linear you
you brought that up about like taking
moments from the Ender from finales or
from key moments and play it out other
trailers we've discussed that I'm sure
we'll discuss during this segment at
some point that will use moments from
late in the movie for intrigue effect
like to bring us and be like oh what's
that all about if you mix up the order
of things it's easier to kind of blend
them in oh yeah do that alright well do
you guys think that we should do this
segment for YouTube I feel like good and
I feel I mean not every chairs gonna be
as like shockingly off yeah I feel like
at its best we could we could do
something to deconstruct trailers are a
thing now it's it's they have awards for
trailers and trailers are a thing that
get their own trailers they're their own
little events and there are their own
little stories now and there are people
who cut them and you can see people's
stamps okay these trailers for trailers
for this 15 second teaser totally
because they are such an actual thing
now I feel like it might be worth it to
sort of if we spend all of our time
digesting them anyway might as well look
and see if they were effective or not
people complain about trailers and that
equates to the performance of a movie
arguably we're doing a service service
trailers examined all kinds of titles
well let us know in the comments guys
for ever watch this video hopefully you
enjoyed